[Musique]
à quoi ça sert de vivre pourquoi y at il
des choses si difficile dans la vie
à quoi servent les épreuves et les
souffrances qui nous tombe dessus
depuis que je suis toute petite j'ai pas
cessé de chercher des réponses à cette
question je sais bien que je suis pas la
seule
mais chez moi ça a toujours été une
véritable quête obsessionnelle faut dire
que j'avais tendance à surtout voir les
côtés sombres de la vie autour de moi et
en général dans le monde
les injustices les maladies les
méchancetés toutes les choses terribles
que des humains inflige à d'autres
humains tout ça me rendait malheureuse
et me sidéré surtout je crois et je
trouvais ça d'autant plus
incompréhensible que m'avait parlé d'un
dieu amour à l'origine de toute chose et
qu'ils voulaient notre bien ce dieu là
qui avait rendu mon frère lourdement
handicapé dès la naissance
c'était pas vraiment logique
alors comme je voyais aucun sens à la
vie
ben j'ai voulu mourir
ça a commencé vers l'âge de 15 ans je
l'aimais mais criant en grosses lettres
capitales sur mon journal intime
je veux mourir en fait j'ai jamais
vraiment tenté de me suicider
naïvement je priais le soir pour plus
jamais me réveiller
ça a duré quelques années comme ça et
puis un jour j'ai réalisé que c'était un
peu idiot de mourir sans avoir compris
le sens de la vie je me suis dit si la
vie semble ne pas avoir de sens à cause
de ces épreuves
c'est peut-être que ce serait le sens
des épreuves qui donnerait un sens à la
vie
je me suis donc mis en quête de
comprendre mes souffrances
j'ai cherché dans plein de directions
des plus rationnelles au plus
ésotériques à l'autre bout du monde est
en moi j'ai parcouru la planète les
livres les formations les conférences
les stages les sagesses ancien la
physique quantique la séance de psy et
j'ai fini par comprendre le pourquoi de
mon mal être mais j'étais en frustrer
parce que j'avais pas encore compris le
pourquoi puisque dans ma petite tête
tout ce qui existe à une raison d'être
je me suis donc posé la question de
l'utilité de mes épreuves quoi est ce
qu'elles peuvent bien servir
j'ai eu un début de réponse douze ans
après le début de mes investigations on
est le vendredi 29 octobre 2004 je
m'apprête à sortir de chez moi pour
partir avec son provence pour assister
au congrès de la fédération de médecine
traditionnelle chinoise
toute contente parce que j'allais
récupérer mon diplôme d'acupuncture et
pile à ce moment là on sonne à la porte
et là je tombe sur un homme avec un
grand couteau qui me jette violemment à
l'intérieur de chez mory sûrs ils
hurlent qui va me tuer et que je vais
payer pour toutes les autres
je comprends que c'est maintenant je
vais mourir mais je peux vous dire que
l'agent n'est plus du tout envie
il est là à hurler face à moi avec son
couteau et je me dis quitte à mourir
autant tenter quelque chose pour me
défendre est juste là j'entends comme
une petite voix qui me dit reste au
calme ne fait rien alors sans vraiment
le décidé presque malgré moi je ferme
les yeux je me mets en posture de
méditation avec une une prière dans
laquelle je demande de l'aide
je suis dans un cocon je perçois plus le
monde extérieur et en même temps je suis
comme hyper connecté à quelque chose
d'immense je perd la notion du temps et
au bout d'un moment
j'entendais pas s'éloigner et la porte
de l'appartement se refermer quand j'ai
réalisé qu'il était parti je me suis
mise à trembler j'étais totalement et
rue comme hébété d'être toujours en vie
et en même temps bien bien secouer parce
que je venais de frôler la mort quand
même et malgré ce choc
je suis quand même parti à aix en
provence où j'ai encore eu une grande
émotion parce qu'au début du congrès un
intervenant a commencé son discours en
disant la prière lorsqu'elle est suivie
d'une réponse c'est plus une prière
c'est une communication
or la veille de mon agression par hasard
dans une librairie j'étais tombé sur la
même citation
sur le moment j'ai pas vraiment prêté
attention et laon l'arrêt en entendant
j'ai réalisé qu'elle avait encadré mon
agression comme pour me délivrer un
message et là ça a été un électrochoc
j'ai été submergé d'une émotion
tellement forte que j'ai dû sortir de la
salle je ressentais un mélange de joie
intense et d' immense gratitude
vis-à-vis de mon agresseur parce qu'il
m'avait permis d'expérimenter une sorte
de connexion à quelqu'un avec quelque
chose qui nous dépasse avec lequel nous
sommes en lien et là j'ai commencé à
comprendre qu'une épreuve pouvait être
juste une étape avec des conséquences
positives
quelques temps après j'ai eu le besoin
d'écrire pour ne rien oublier de toutes
les coïncidences de tous les liens entre
les les choses qui avaient précédé et
suivi cet épisode passion n'a eu
beaucoup et je me suis rendu compte que
chaque ingrédient de ma vie du plus
anodin au plus marquants du plus
malheureux au plus heureux étaient comme
les pièces d'un puzzle qui s'agencent de
façon juste et logique et quelques
années plus tard j'ai eu l'idée d'en
faire un livre pour partager un message
qui pourrait être utile à d'autres nous
épreuve
en dix ans elle semble des étapes
façonnant notre destinée et notre
bonheur vous inquiétez pas je fais pas
l'apologie des drames je vous incite pas
à aller draguer un psychopathe pour
connaître votre avenir
c'est juste une invitation à pas voir
nos malheurs comme des calamités
statique mais comme des dynamiques qui
crée le mouvement de la vie vous avez
remarqué que certains accidents de la
vie nous font prendre des orientations
inattendues qui s'avère bonne pour nous
comme si ça avait été un détonateur
désagréable pour pas dire bien mais
finalement bénéfique
un peu comme dans la chanson d'alain
souchon
la balade de jim vous savez on peut
rencontrer la femme de sa vie grâce à un
accident de voiture donc du bon voire du
très bon peut découler d'événements
douloureux mais ce que j'ai découvert
c'est que c'est au sein même de ce qui
nous éprouve que réside la germe le
germe de notre destinée de notre bonheur
et qu'il y à un moyen de le décoder
en fait on pourrait lire nos épreuves au
sens photographique du terme
nous faisons un zoom sur le négatif on
pourrait y deviner l'image positive qui
est son inverse
c'est d'ailleurs ce que dit un peu le
taoïsme avec la tonalité inyang pour
comprendre le blanc ben on a besoin du
contraste du noir
si on souffre du froid on va aller
chercher la chaleur et on l'appréciera
d'autant plus qu'on en a été privé on
pourra même développé une habileté
particulière à trouver de la chaleur
voir avoir très envie de partager sa
passion pour le show en réaction à nos
souffrances naissent de façon plus ou
moins consciente des moteurs et des
talents en lien avec l'opposé de ce qui
nous a créés et de la souffrance
par exemple si on se sont enfermés à
entraver on va avoir envie de s'échapper
et on donne on va développer des
facultés pour se libérer
l'idée d'enfermement essien supportable
qu'on va tout faire pour favoriser la
liberté ou la libération pour nous mêmes
et dans notre vie sociale
ce soit à la manière d'un nelson mandela
d'un général de gaulle d'un psy ou d'un
avocat
quelle que soit la forme que ça prend si
on ne vend la liberté quelque part c'est
qu'on en a été privé de la même manière
que si on a un désir ardent de justice
c'est vraisemblablement qu'on a ressenti
un fort sentiment d'injustice et on peut
continuer comme ça avec maladie guérison
de tigres en abandon lien solitude
collectif silence communication extra
dsta il ya une ligne de dualité qui me
tient particulièrement à coeur
c'est celle du masculin féminin si l'on
notre enfance on n'avait pas loin
d'exprimer ses émotions ou si on était
une petite fille et que nos parents
voulaient un garçon ou si on a été
victime d'abus sexuels alors on aura
tendance à refouler ses dimensions
féminine parce qu'elle représente un
danger ou pour faire plaisir aux parents
les dimensions féminine dans le taoïsme
s'est pas seulement la féminité c'est
aussi par exemple notre fibre sensible
émotionnel et donc si on a vécu quelque
chose de cet ordre
on pourra vraisemblablement être animé
d'un désir là encore pas forcément
conscients d'oeuvrer à la libération à
l'émancipation de ses valeurs féminines
qui auront été bridée bafouée voile est
inféodée à des diktats plus masculin ça
pourra se faire par exemple en militant
pour le droit des femmes mais aussi en
favorisant l'expression émotionnelle
artistique voire pourquoi pas en
devenant spécialiste de la sexualité
tantrique ses moteurs et ses talents qui
proviennent donc de nos souffrances
deviennent des caractéristiques fortes
de notre personnalité a minima en
potentiel à exploiter et façonnent notre
destinée en nous mettant en chemin vers
notre domaine d'excellence de désir et
de plaisir et on pourrait donner une
dimension plus spirituelle à tout ça
dans mon chemin dans ma quête de
comprendre les souffrances
j'ai exploré plusieurs s'agisse du monde
comme le taoïsme donc vu aussi la
kabbale la mythologie grecque et bien
d'autres et si j'avais en faire une
synthèse
j'utiliserai cette citation de pierre
teilhard de chardin
nous ne sommes pas des êtres humains en
quête d'une aventure spirituelle
nous sommes des êtres spirituels vivent
une aventure humaine et si notre âme
décider de son carnet sur terre pour
connaître à expérimenter des choses dans
la matière dans un corps humain
hypothèse mont ham souhaite incarner
pour comprendre ce qu'est la liberté
pour vrai et la liberté
pour ça il faut que j'ai un désir fort
de liberté est ce qu'on désire ce qu'on
a déjà
ben non pour éprouver le désir ça
implique que j'en a été privé ça
nécessite donc que dès le début de ma
vie je sois victime d'une sorte
d'enfermement qu'il soit psychologique
ou physique
et si ce désir n'est pas encore comblé
j'aurai la chance de rencontrer des
grands méchants loups qui vont m'aider à
me mettre dans la bonne voie en me
bousculant régulièrement quitte à me
faire souffrir pour que je réagisse
jusqu'à ce que je réagisse au fond
lucifer c'est mon meilleur ami luxe
ferry en latin ça va bien dire porteur
de lumière et satan moi je l'appelle mon
coach sportif en hébreu il est le celui
qui met à l'épreuve
on peut donc voir nous épreuve aussi au
sens sportif du terme ce qui nous fait
du mal nous permet de nous dépasser pour
accoucher de nous mêmes il est
d'ailleurs dit dans l'ancien testament
tu enfanteras dans la douleur on peut
l'entendre comme l'injonction d'un dieu
vengeur qui punit eve on peut le voir
aussi comme une allégorie dans la
douleur tu enfanteras c'est dans la
souffrance que tu puisera à l'énergie
pour accoucher de trois mêmes
ce changement de regard sur ce qui nous
éprouve savoir la bouse de vache comme
un engrais qui nourrit des fleurs et pas
juste comme de la merde il s'agit pas de
nier la souffrance mais de nous mettre
dans une énergie qui ouvre les possibles
plutôt que de se focaliser sur la
douleur si on est révolté par les
inégalités hommes femmes par les
violences faites aux femmes se lamenter
dénoncé le fléau et punir les fautifs
ça suffira sans doute pas mais en
regardant le problème comme étant le
miroir de nos propres dimension féminine
que nous dénigrons nous mêmes
ça ça peut générer une prise de
conscience qui est le premier pas vers
la guérison et vers l'accomplissement de
soi tout en désactivant le problème
parce qu'on aura plus besoin c'est à
dire ce que suggèrent certains peuples
premiers
je pense notamment à la tradition aux
ponots ponot de hawaï
il considère que le monde est le reflet
de soi même les problèmes il les
remercie et il les honore car ils sont
justement une opportunité d'identifier
un problème analogue à l'intérieur de
soi pour évoluer pour grandir en
conscience on retrouve cette idée dans
des contes pour enfants et même dans des
films américains avec des super héros
c'est l'ennemi le défi le méchant
monstre le dark vador qui nous pousse à
devenir un héros à partir à l'aventuré à
la quête de notre graal
vers notre légende personnelle quand mon
livre est sorti j'ai une conférence sur
le thème nos épreuves sur nos fidèles
alliés car elle mène à notre destinée et
après la conférence dont les gens sont
venus me voir en me demandant si je
faisais des accompagnements individuels
pour les aider à décoder le soc de leur
épreuve et ça ça m'a donné l'impulsion
pour me lancer dans cette voie qui
aujourd'hui d'un un sens à ma vie en
fait j'ai été confronté à la mort pour
que je comprenne le sens de ma vie aider
les autres à comprendre le sens de la
leur je voudrais terminer ce témoignage
par un mélange de sagesse de confucius
gandhi et young avec un soupçon
d'alchimie le monde est à notre image
si on trouve le sens de notre vie en
transformant ce qui nous plombe en
trésors
alors nous serons en harmonie avec nous
mêmes et si nous sommes son harmonie
avec nous mêmes alors il y aura de la
monnaie dans le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]